[Applause]
[Music]
there
[Music]
zero casualties
idea of the game three in a row
good luck emil good luck first shot
[Applause]
good first shot
oh close this is actually pretty intense
still no pops hit the middle one that's
the best one to hit
[Music]
i hit the side of them
i'll start the game now okay start
playing
oh
it touched it touched the balloon but it
didn't [ __ ]
bullseye
okay that looks pretty cool
it felt pretty cool
the playing field has been opened
boom
it's a pretty good spot
[Music]
okay that was unexpected
middle pink is what i'm going for
that's a good one for me now all i need
is the yellow one i'll have to aim for
that one next this is where the game
gets interesting
[Music]
more of those please
almost two
i was so nervous it would have been like
three in a row so the one who gets that
wins a deciding one
there
yeah that's good
yes neither one pop i found
it's got very intense
that's
no
wow
oh no
that missed completely
three circles emil takes the game
and guys there is still 76 of you guys
who haven't subscribed so help us out
and do it now until next time
oh no don't do it
does it look even remotely as a circle
no
we need all same